will you pray with me spirit of the
Living God unstop our ears and free us
to proclaim the good news with our
mouths and with our lives amen when I
was in seminary one of my professors
taught me that if you want to read
scripture like a rabbi it's kind of like
taking a bit of wool and wiping it
across the surface of the text you look
for the places where it snags and so
when I was reading the gospel text this
week and I got to the part where jesus
said let the children be fed first for
it is not right to take the children's
food and throw it to the dogs I hit a
pretty big snag there I don't know if
it's the same for you but it's that one
line that really kind of grabs you and
sticks out and it's hard to pay
attention to much else after that once
you've heard it because it sticks out so
much so if it sticks out to you rest
assured that is good it's supposed to I
think mark has really kind of set it up
that way I mean even from the very first
chapter of Mark Jesus pops up on the
scene in Galilee proclaiming the good
news to all the people saying the time
is now God is near everybody gather
around and immediately he starts healing
people left and right everyone is cured
demons are cast out and that the fame
spreads throughout the region of the
works that he's doing and the crowds
begin to gather by chapter 2 the house
is so packed where he is staying that
people are lined up outside the door
others are on top of the roof tearing it
off to get down into him by chapter 3
the crowd is so huge that Jesus has
perched himself in a boat just off the
shore so that he won't be crushed by the
people and everywhere always repeatedly
Jesus see
use the people with pity and compassion
and heals them and restores them to new
life always every single time until you
get to chapter seven by seven we know
the story pretty well right the woman
hears she comes she boughs down she begs
for healing on behalf of someone else
not necessarily for herself it's a
little different in different stories
but we know what's supposed to come next
so when Jesus says this time not yet
it's actually not yours and it's not
fair for me to heal you it totally
disrupts everything that we were
expecting I mean don't you feel cheated
where is the healing Jesus this is not
how the story is supposed to go this
isn't the gospel and the good news that
we know well it turns out that the good
news that the time is now and God is
near is only good news for Galilee not
for tyre not for women from Sarah
phoenicia I imagine for Mark's original
audience this kind of cut two ways for
all of the Gentile converts who were
suddenly making claims to this new and
bold covenant it took them down a notch
right it's a reminder that you know
actually this covenant doesn't belong to
you you weren't even a part of it it
kind of disrupts I guess any claims to
self righteousness or exclusion and then
for the Jews the members of that early
church it affirms their primary claim to
God's promised Kingdom and it reassures
their place as the children of God but I
also imagine that if any of those Jewish
listeners were feeling particularly smug
and self-righteous themselves after
hearing it they would be surprised to
find out the
that's not the end of the story mark it
turns out is setting them up as well so
if you keep reading a little ways we
find that we get tripped up on this
initial statement so that we start to
pay attention to where we're standing
and where we're stepping because what
comes next is even more radical even
more shocking than what came before this
woman's reaction her response to that
riddle is not to bite or to snarl or to
just go away too bad no healing for you
instead she in her position bowed down
at Jesus's feet takes on that metaphor
and expands it even wider to say even
the dogs eat the crumbs from beneath the
table this anonymous woman has humbled
herself on behalf of her beloved child
out of loyalty and compassion with great
hope that Jesus will free her from the
powers that have gripped her life and
hold her hostage she has stepped into
this metaphor that insults her and
degrades her so that her daughter might
be healed and restored to new life she
witnesses to God's abundant and
overflowing grace and proclaims to Jesus
even now there is enough there is plenty
that all might eat and be satisfied
Jesus sees in her actions and here's in
her words the very substance of his own
gospel she is reflecting the image of
God before him and he names it as the
gospel you don't really get that as much
in the way that the the NRSV translates
like oh well for saying that you can go
on home it's actually for preaching this
word for proclaiming this gospel you can
go your daughter has been
madewell it's not even that Jesus
changes his mind about healing her child
it's also that Jesus changes his mission
from that point forward he instead of
going on back to Galilee after he's had
a rest goes back to tire and back to
Galilee by way of Sidon to Decapolis
which is like you know I mean maybe for
me being new to New Haven I would take a
really roundabout way to get somewhere
but jesus knows where he is he knows
where is going it's sort of odd that he
would wind up wandering that far away
from Galilee on his way home and so we
see this kind of drastic shift in
Jesus's mission from that point forward
and so I think what's so interesting
about this is that this anonymous woman
I mean we know nothing about her except
that she is Greek that she is an
outsider of the kingdom of the Covenant
of the people of God that this outsider
woman bears the image of God in the
world and the really mind stretching
part of it to me is that it's by
claiming her position as a dog under the
table that she reveals just how truly a
child of God she is that she embodies
the very way that Jesus embodies life in
the world and I think it reminded me of
back in chapter 4 when Jesus says who is
my mother who are my brothers the people
who do the will of God that is my family
and here sitting before him reflecting
back to him the image of God is this
woman that he then claims as his own I
think the insult itself as shocking as
it is is just there to get us to the
next part and I don't want to dismiss it
you know scholars have spent many many
years trying to explain it and defend it
and soften it because the words out of
Jesus
mouths are so harsh the truth is I don't
know if jesus said this particular thing
to this particular woman in this
particular way but what I do know is
that it's a word of truth to that early
church which was suffering a lot of
division at the time and it's also a
word of truth for all of us today
because it disrupts any exclusive claim
that we would make bike on God it blurs
all of the lines of who's inside and
who's outside and who has access and who
doesn't it's a call for all of us to
humility it's a reminder that God's
grace doesn't belong to one group or the
other that God's promises and God's
healing are neither something that is
owed to us nor something that we own for
ourselves it's purely gift it reminds us
that we are all of us guests within
God's grace but it's also a reminder
that we ourselves are empowered to claim
our place within that covenant because
we have been invited and that we do that
by living into the kind of life that
Jesus lived by showing within our own
lives the way that Jesus made himself
last made himself servant to others
accepted the ways that he was not
accepted in the world we know that
that's the way the world works but we're
invited to be a different kind of
community and in her witness I find
great hope so friends the time indeed is
now and God is near let's get started
amen